Um,
so I'd like to thank you all for showing up here today in person and those of
you on the live stream for showing up to support each other.
Um,
I think many of us have been affected either directly or indirectly by suicide.
and it's something that we want to make sure we're addressing specifically so
everyone knows that they're not alone.
Um,
before we get started,
this is kind of a challenging topic to navigate.
There are tons of resources available to all of us here within Google and
beyond.
Uh,
before we get started today,
we think it's very important to understand a little bit of the statistics around
suicide and why this is such a critical topic for us to be discussing.
It is the 10th leading cause of death in the United States.
We will lose 40,000 Americans who will die by suicide this year and there will
be approximately 500,000 attempts this year.
Today alone,
we will lose a 117 Americans to suicide.
These are very shocking statistics and it's alarming and it's why we're bringing
people together today to discuss the importance of this topic and discuss the
importance of finding a space for those talks.
Um,
I'd like to welcome Jessica to Vento,
Dr Jessica de Vento who worked very hard for that title.
Um,
she is going to be moderating the discussion today with the wonderful folks from
the s word film.
She is an employee mental health program manager and business advisor at Google.
Prior to Google she worked primarily in university health and corporate employee
assistance and she specialist that specializes in crisis management and critical
incident response as well as treating anxiety,
trauma and young adult professionals.
She has over a decade of experience treating hundreds of suicidal clients and
has been affected by this issue.
Personally,
please welcome Jessica.
Thank you
very much.
I'm very happy to be here and what I'm going to do is I'm going to introduce our
panelists up and then we're going to roll the trailer for the club.
And just as a reminder,
we do have a Jana here for those of you if you want to talk.
And as we set the tone and intention a day just for folks to be mindful that
since it is a sensitive topic,
please have laptops and screens down.
If you're able and be mindful if you have a reaction,
totally normal human reaction.
Um,
to this topic,
feel free to do what you need to take care of yourself,
but be mindful and respectful of those around you when you do so.
So first I'd like to introduce Lisa client.
She's the director of the film.
Lisa.
Lisa is an all
Lisa is an award winning documentary rest and she's done multiple films focused
on mental health and uh,
it's a passion project for her,
the s word as she both her brother and father,
uh,
die from suicide.
And Lisa also cones mad picks,
which is based locally in La.
And it she runs it with her husband,
right?
Yup.
Thank you.
And now I'd also like to invite Anne Taylor to the state.
And is featured in the documentary and she's a suicide survivor.
And so she'll be talking about her experience today.
She's a single mother of two adult children now,
right?
Two adult men and she has attempted suicide four times between the years of 2009
and 2012 and I'm so grateful she can be here with us today.
And thankfully she supported by a therapist and a psychiatrist.
She also currently works as a crisis counselor and as a peer facilitator from
the Didi Hirsch Mental Health Services Center locally.
So if we go ahead and roll the trailer please.
Okay.
I remember thinking I just hold on cause somehow some way this is going to make
sense.
The reaction of people around me,
let's just shut up.
Anybody who has lost anyone through suicide,
you always say,
what did I miss?
Why couldn't I say,
Yep,
suicide.
That's scary word,
isn't it?
I just always felt like an alien,
like a burden.
I started to look for other people like me and I couldn't find anything.
Like where were these people
to say I'm an attempt survivor.
Even say the word suicide is a racket stopper.
I just want people to look into these people's eyes because we've always looked
away,
you know,
Hashtag [inaudible] suicide.
So white.
My name is Leah Harris and I am
survivor.
When I grew up the,
I'm an activist and I'm a nice seven advocate.
It's a project about suicide,
but I'm focusing on life.
It's not the word suicide.
That is the problem.
It is the deafening silence around it.
We lose a hundred to 12 people every day.
That's bigger than a small jet airplanes.
I'm not doing well.
I find myself wanting to hurt myself.
I just don't really know how to handle it.
A revolution in mental health is happening and we are at the forefront,
so it's still an option for you.
I don't want it to be,
we're changing a culture more and more.
It becomes clear to me that I am never alone,
that we are never ever alone.
What would you say to suicide?
What was a thing?
If it was a person,
I'd say suck it
s word.
It's only scary if you give it this sort of boogie man.
Wait,
I used to think,
man,
maybe in life just isn't for everybody.
I was done and I was wrong.
It's here.
It's not coming soon.
It's already available.
So please watch the film if you haven't done so already.
Um,
I just appreciate that trailer so much.
I'm so glad that we're here having this conversation and I'm so grateful for
both of you being here.
I just want to say that.
Lisa,
why did you make the film?
That's a great question.
And,
um,
there were several reasons,
but so when I was in college,
both my father and my brother died by suicide,
as you said.
And it wasn't an immediate,
I,
okay,
I need to do something.
But you know,
over the years just writing about it,
trying to process it,
seeing a therapist,
you know,
going through all of,
all of this stuff.
And prior to this film we did a film about bipolar and there was somebody in the
film who had lost her daughter to suicide.
And I thought,
okay,
I'm done.
I've dealt with it,
I'm good.
And then I realized in two seconds I just wasn't.
And um,
so as altruistic as this may seem like,
Oh wow,
you really did this great.
Part of it was for me,
you know,
it was my process.
And I started researching and I started,
um,
as you know,
coming from a place of loss.
So I was,
you know,
googling,
um,
this,
you know,
I was,
I was on the Internet and I was,
I was looking for people and,
and all of that.
And,
um,
what I found was sort of this just amazing kind of,
I like,
I found Deseret first,
you know,
I found,
lived through this and then I went to the American,
so American Association of suicidology conference and I started this whole
process and I realized there's just this like vibrant group of people who are,
who had attempted suicide and survived these,
these people with lived experience.
And I was like,
well,
these are the people I need to talk to.
I mean,
these are the people who can tell me,
you know,
who can tell the world about their experiences and all of that.
And I just thought it was really to,
the silence is just not helping anything.
If anything,
the silence is killing,
you know,
as many people as,
as suicide,
you know.
I mean,
because you know,
by not talking about you're taking something so difficult to deal with and then
you're trapping it even more by not talking about it.
And it just didn't seem,
it seemed wrong to me.
And I want it to get the conversation going so well.
I'm so glad you did.
Cause I know this has really prompted not just this conversation but so many
more and the work that you do with schools and things like that around the
country.
So powerful.
And why did you agree to be in the film?
Uh,
I was approached to be in this film if I was interested in sharing my
experience.
Um,
I was very,
very hesitant.
I was very scared.
Um,
what I was feeling myself with a lot of shame,
feeling isolated,
feeling alone,
feeling like I'd done something terribly wrong.
And,
um,
and it was that shame for myself that I wanted to express to people what I was
going through and what I was feeling and how,
I know there's other people that are going through this too.
So,
um,
so I agreed to do this.
I was very hesitant,
but I did agree to do this and I,
it was for me to help me to spread the word of what I was going through,
but also to,
um,
allow other people to possibly be able to talk about their own situation.
And it's very,
very isolating and there's a lot of shame that goes with it,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
I hear you.
And I'm just so glad that you did choose to speak out and break that stigma of
shame that's around it.
Yeah.
And it sounds like Lisa gave you that space to be the container,
but also to have a voice now for the world.
Right,
exactly.
And that kind of started everything.
And then I realized,
Gosh,
you know,
I've been given a little bit of a platform here.
I'm not much of a public speaker and really don't like to share these things so
much,
but I was given that chance to say something to the world.
And so I'm trying to do that as best I can.
So I thank you for having us here today and allowing that discussion.
Yeah,
thank you so much.
Very,
very powerful that you all are here with us today.
Can we go ahead and roll the clip of an,
there are parts of me
of which I'm glad I'm alive,
but there's many parts of me that I really wish I wasn't.
I don't know if I'm really safe.
I don't know if I'm out of the woods yet.
When was your last attempt?
Two and a half years ago.
I have two really amazing kids.
That's the reason I'm still alive.
Okay.
I mean,
when you first told me I was just,
that was a curve with shock to begin,
but I think you're taking your own life.
That's scary and sad.
Yeah.
Shouldn't happen.
Sorry.
I mean like hearing that it,
if I'm in my heart,
drop in like
is Kevin and I'm catching up with him.
You don't even want to think about,
but I know I needed to.
I never ever would want to leave you or hurt you.
I don't know.
Cool.
I'm really glad you did.
Tell me this.
I think you're stronger than I did before because you're going out and reaching
out and telling me,
okay.
I want to be there for you.
If you need help
on wake up and see the day go,
it's a new day.
This is awesome.
This is what I want.
Okay.
I just want to say I'm so touched by the bond you and your son have and that
special moment.
Yeah,
we are.
We are very close.
So we talk about these things and yeah.
Um,
that was an incredible moment that the two of us were able to share together
that Lisa captured that Lisa captured.
So yeah,
the three of us.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
And that makes me teary every time I watch it.
And just the thoughtfulness and insightfulness that he had at such a young age.
He was 18,
18 at the time.
Yeah.
How is it to watch yourself on film?
No.
Um,
well then at the time I was obviously very nervous and very scared and,
and I think when you look at yourself on film,
you don't really see what you think you look like and what you sound like.
So it felt very strange and very awkward.
Um,
I've watched it enough times now that I'm comfortable with it.
And as difficult as that conversation was,
uh,
I'm so glad that we had that and I'm so glad that other people have been able to
see that.
Um,
so I look at myself on the film and I feel very proud.
I feel like I've taken some great steps forward and two,
um,
hopefully decreasing that stigma of suicide.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm curious,
Lisa,
how was it for you to be in the room as people are sharing these stories?
Either watching,
I know Deseret interviewing folks and some,
and then it looked like a,
your conversation with them and others.
Are you talking about like,
yeah,
like in the room as we're interviewing and we're talking and all of that.
Yeah,
it was,
it was really important.
And,
and just like the first time that we talked to Anne for example,
was,
um,
we had her psychiatrist sitting behind me because it was,
it was one of those things that like whatever is going to make you comfortable
and if he's here,
you know,
I mean,
we really tried to,
you know,
make it a,
a comfortable situation and it,
what was really important and what I realized,
like I may have had my,
uh,
my questions,
like,
you have your,
your questions there,
but it becomes a dialogue,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
so if I just sit there and say,
you know,
and I want you to tell me this,
you can ask me whatever too.
I mean,
I've been in a different space in suicide.
Um,
but please,
let's just talk about this.
Let's just talk about it.
So it was pretty emotional a lot of the times.
I mean the,
the,
the clip that you saw,
like when she was sitting with Sam,
I mean,
that was really beautiful.
I am sure that I was tearing up behind the camera.
We were,
you know,
both of us where the camera person in me and talking to as I as I told you
before,
like,
like Brandon's mother,
you know,
I mean there were some,
some moments that were um,
real like,
wow,
this is really happening.
I mean these people are talking about the probably the scariest,
most difficult moments of their lives and their interesting this and we better
not screw this up.
You know?
I mean it was,
there was pressure to,
it's like how do we handle this?
And when,
when we were cutting it too,
it's like we've got these people literally their live not to sound so dramatic
but their lives in our hands a little bit,
you know.
And um,
we really wanted them,
like for an to say,
I feel proud of myself watching it means the world because that's what we wanted
to do,
you know?
And when the truth comes out,
what's coming up for me right now and what resonates with me,
it's like our ability to tolerate the discomfort of sharing our story or of
holding the space for folks so that we can have the conversation.
Because the conversation is just so taboo and so stigmatized in our society and
for those of us that can take that on and hold space for that really allows us
to move forward because we're not going to get the traction we need otherwise.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
Yeah,
that's very cool.
Something that stuck out to me in the film was the language that was used around
suicide and myself as a mental health professional,
I reflected a lot about that kind of during and after the film.
And I've heard it a bit and the site community,
but seeing it on film was just really powerful to get that message out
specifically around the phrase committed suicide,
uh,
versus died by suicide.
If you want to either of you want to speak more to that.
I had started and then you pick however you want to do it.
But,
um,
yeah,
I mean I learned as,
as we were doing this and then,
I mean,
I can't remember ever saying committed suicide when I think about when I,
when I talked about my brother and my father,
but I'm,
I must have I guess,
but I,
I don't know,
like now it's completely out of my vernacular I guess.
But in talking to Desiree,
like when we were talking that day and even prior to that,
like Layo very much educated me about a lot of stuff.
Leah,
who's in the film as well.
But when we were talking about it,
I mean Desiree's whole point and a lot of people in the,
um,
suicide prevention,
mental health community talk about commit being such a wasted word.
You know,
we commit murder,
commit rape,
but as,
as,
um,
fell Dez,
his wife,
now wife says,
you know,
we also,
commit to marriage commit,
you know,
so it's,
it's a thing,
you know,
like there were some people on the side that say,
once you start getting rid of what,
you know,
pretty soon we're not going to be able to talk at all because all the words are
going to be gone.
So when somebody,
you know,
so it's,
uh,
it's,
it's definitely a thing and I do prefer to say died by suicide.
I mean,
it's clear,
you know,
commit really does.
Again,
it's,
it's very strong and it's very like I decided that I am going to commit this
action and you know,
so you might have a more,
well,
I think also that a long time ago,
I don't even know how many years ago,
um,
suicide was considered a crime and was considered a sin and that has kind of
carried through where people have just said committed suicide.
It's just gone on for so long that it's carried through into now.
And that's just a term that's been used.
And,
um,
really it's when I hear committed suicide,
it makes me feel like I'm a felon or I've done something terribly wrong and I
should be abolished or band or whatever it is.
But so,
so I cringe when I hear that word.
And I would prefer to say that,
you know,
they died by suicide.
You know,
it's,
it's more what it is,
you know,
committed as a very hard,
strong word.
I can see both sides of it,
but to me I think it's just something that's carried through the years and
gotten rid of.
Yeah.
It sounds like it also enhances and increases the shame around it.
Absolutely.
And,
um,
I just want to acknowledge too,
in some countries it is still criminalized and a very difficult to address it in
some,
some ways because of that.
Yeah.
And it's not a crime.
And Desiree has been mentioned a couple of times in our conversation.
I know that she was in the clips.
She's the one for those of,
you haven't seen the film yet taking the pictures and uh,
she,
she had her project live,
lived through this.
Right.
This,
yes.
I'm curious to know your experience working with Desiree cause she's highlighted
a lot in the foam.
Both.
I know Lisa you said she's the first one you found and kind of reached out to
for her project and then she took photos at you.
Right.
So I'm curious about your experiences working with her.
Sure.
So my experience with Dez is I'm doing the interview,
what you saw,
she asked me a series of different questions and we talked about suicide,
what it means to me and um,
and my different experiences with the hospitals or whatever situation I was put
in.
Um,
for me,
Dez was,
um,
appear.
She was somebody who has been there,
who is,
who understands what it feels like to reach that awful point and to actually
cross the line and try to take her own life.
There's like this line there.
And I think people who have attempted in gone that far have some sort of
internal connection with other and immediately I felt connected to does and was
willing to tell her anything.
And um,
I kind of feel like we're walking through this journey together and you know,
she's my traveling partner in a sense as with other people who have attempted
to,
there's definitely a tight bond.
So does,
is an amazing person.
Amazing person.
So I'm lucky to have gotten to know her.
Yeah.
I mean when I,
when I saw her project,
the fact that,
I mean,
because who are you going to talk to again about the,
the most difficult time of your life written him somebody who's,
who's been there and she has been there and what's really struck me in talking
to her was her idea of the way she does her portraits,
which we'll,
we'll see at some point is she has this whole thing about,
look,
you know,
look into my eyes,
look into the Lens.
Because oftentimes with something like suicide,
something like,
you know,
somebody who has attempted suicide,
we tend to look away and she didn't want them to look away.
You know,
her whole point is let's look at these people.
Let's listen to them when she interviewed and talked to them and,
and all of that.
And then we realize somewhere,
you know,
I think I was a little slow on the uptake because I realized as we were going,
it was probably a year in that,
oh,
you know what,
this is probably going to be the center piece because she's taking pictures and
were photographed and like,
we're doing this together.
And,
and it really did,
it did become kind of a partnership,
like even sharing,
like we introduced her to Ann and she introduced us to,
um,
let's Craig or whoever,
you know,
I mean,
so it really did become a partnership of,
of,
um,
who we were talking to and how we were doing it.
And we just sort of converged on that.
And I just want to acknowledge,
correct me if I'm wrong again,
but she took this photo here,
right?
Yeah,
she did take that photo.
Yeah.
It's a very serious picture.
But if you look in my eyes,
you can see that there's something in there.
There's some pain in there,
some hope that I could be supported or,
or helped or I dunno.
But it's like you can make everything up and do your hair all fancy and put
makeup on everything.
But when you look in people's eyes,
you see a lot.
Yeah.
She captured the essence of it.
And in a really cute [inaudible] it right.
Having you here,
you know,
to give that extra voice to it.
It's,
and I look at that picture and that's what I felt like at the time.
So,
yeah.
Whatever that means.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I'm curious,
as we're talking about suicide,
um,
and we're talking about the shame about suicide.
I know there's a lot of myths behind suicide,
um,
that the,
that are propagated just kind of through everyday talking to people who do
choose to talk about it.
Are there any myths that you want to debunk here today or anything you wish
people knew about suicide that you think lot of people don't know?
Well,
the coward myth,
um,
I think,
you know,
that it's such a cowardly thing to do because I mean,
I was,
um,
18 I was just,
just about 18 when my father died.
And,
um,
I didn't know right away.
I mean,
it was hidden from it.
There was a whole family of shame thing.
And then when I,
when I found out and the,
and the idea of,
you know,
God,
you know what a cowardly act he left,
he left his family,
he left his kids,
he left his thing.
And that was the narrative that I sort of learned.
And I,
I never wanted to embrace it because I really did hold my father on a pedestal.
And so what I've sort of learned or what I've chosen to learn,
because I can create my own narrative because he's not here to tell me anything
at this point.
And so I tried to,
I think that I look at it as more co,
I mean,
I don't want to say,
you know,
well suicide,
that's,
that's the most courageous thing you can do.
But in a,
in a way for him,
he waited until I was the youngest of three kids and he waited until I was in
college.
So,
I mean,
I tried to flip it,
you know,
to,
um,
him thinking it through and realizing that,
you know,
I would be okay.
You know,
again,
it's kind of ridiculous,
but still,
you know,
in his own mind of how he,
how he did this and,
and then wondering,
wow,
he must have been struggling for a long time.
Because when people think,
wow,
well that's an impulsive act,
or this person is killing themselves because they broke up with their boyfriend,
or you know,
whatever it is,
it's like realizing that it's,
it's kind of like,
um,
that suicide itself is kind of like Jenga or whatever,
you know,
I mean,
you,
um,
I'm not always great at metaphors,
but when you,
um,
you know,
there are a lot of pieces,
there are a lot of pieces to this puzzle.
So it isn't just,
you know,
you failed the test so you went out and killed you.
You,
I mean,
because people do want to simplify it because it's easier to say that this
person,
this,
this must have,
this happened.
So this,
you know,
so I mean that,
that,
that's another myth.
But yeah,
and,
and sometimes it is spontaneous with,
with people a suicide attempt.
And other times it's something that has been building up for a long period of
time.
I would say for me,
um,
I,
I was overwhelmed.
I had a series of losses that happened very suddenly together and I became very
overwhelmed and my,
my head was foggy.
And spinning and I couldn't think,
I couldn't act the way I should act.
It just came up on me and I attempted suicide.
So I don't look at it.
I look at it as more of something that was just so terribly overwhelming and
that I felt like if I continued on with this life that I would be a burden to
everybody else and that I would be harming my kids if I stayed alive.
So it's some of those distorted thoughts that happen in that moment.
Um,
I think another thing,
um,
another misconception is that you shouldn't talk about it.
You shouldn't ask people how they're feeling.
Um,
if you're worried about someone who you think might be suicidal,
the most important thing you can do is to actually talk to them and ask them
questions and listen to what they have to say.
And you know,
ask them specifically,
are you having suicidal thoughts?
You know,
that opens a dialogue for that person to say,
okay,
maybe I can share this.
Maybe I could get help.
But if you just walk away and pretend it's not there,
it's going to isolate us even more.
And put us more at risk.
So talking about it is very,
very,
very important.
Yeah.
Because there's a myth,
I'm sorry.
There's a myth that if you bring it up then somebody is going to think about it
and if you really think about it,
um,
if you're going along,
life is fine.
You're doing your thing and somebody says,
you know,
are you thinking about suicide?
And it,
you know,
you can be like,
no,
you know,
I wasn't.
But now that you mentioned,
I think it's a great idea,
that doesn't usually happen that way.
No,
that doesn't have so no inception that happened.
no.
Oh,
let me plant that thought.
Yeah.
I really appreciate that you bring that up because I'm just being able to broach
the conversation,
opens the door for people to get help if they want it at that time.
Yeah.
And if we don't have the conversation on the door,
might not be open.
[inaudible]
oh,
I did think of one other thing.
The other,
the other thing that I learned from,
from you,
from people who had been there,
the idea that because we all,
I think our nature is we want to help.
We want to fix it.
We want to fix that.
We want to fix whatever the problem is.
So the nature,
our nature would tell us,
um,
you know,
somebody who's telling you,
because we do say,
you know,
talk to somebody or whatever.
And oftentimes it's like,
okay,
well here's what you do so you can go to the hospital or you can take medication
or you can see a therapist or you can eat keenwah or you can run or you can,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
I've got the solution for you.
And oftentimes not quite.
That was like,
how about turning it the other way and listening to what they have to say and
what they need.
So that was a big learning thing.
Yeah,
it's so hard.
Both that like the the desire to want to control and help can be so difficult
for the person supporting,
but if they really want to support to have that open ear,
listen with their judgment,
listen without judgment and when people tried to tell you what to do to eat keen
law or whatever it is,
it almost hurts because it feels like
they're not listening.
They're just trying to just get rid of the problem to push it under the rug.
So yeah,
listening I'm listening is the most important thing I could say.
I appreciate it
that,
that you will bring in that here.
I also wanted to address that the myth of the coward.
I'm just,
I don't know.
I had this thought of,
you know,
maybe that's driven by folks who get so angry after people killed themselves and
if they do it that way,
then they don't have to deal with all the other emotions.
Like you said,
they simplify it.
It can,
they can draw it and put it in a box.
But when I appreciate you when you're talking about your dad for example,
is you're shifting to a place of having empathy for the pain that he was in in
that moment.
And I imagine that can be a very powerful place for listeners
porters to be into,
well,
if you look at like,
like somebody who has died of cancer and you know,
this person just fought for the,
you know,
they,
they fought for their life and,
and you know,
here they are and if you have somebody who dies by suicide,
particularly somebody who's in their sixties or fifties or you know,
who they could have been struggling for 30 years,
you know,
and,
and you know,
it,
it is in cancer,
it's whatever is going on that could be,
you know,
unbelievable pain.
So,
you know,
to,
to kind of,
um,
you know,
vilify them or it is,
kind of minimizes what somebody is feeling.
And I think that that really takes away from what's going on.
And again,
I do think,
yeah,
in that specific moment when you decide to act.
I don't think anybody,
I'm not,
I don't know.
But I don't think anybody could be thinking logically and clearly at that point.
I think you've reached a limit where
you're just acting on whatever is telling you to act and it's not,
you're not thinking clearly.
So I want to point that out that I honestly don't think it's a selfish thing.
I can see why people get frustrated and angry with that,
but there's more to it than just trying to end your life because you lost your
job.
There's more to it than that.
There's a lot of layers.
It's usually not layers.
The surface,
the selfishness thing is reading because there is that whole sort of burden
thing.
Like sometimes it's,
it's weirdly selfless in that,
you know,
well,
I'm going to,
I'm going to really,
you know,
relieve this person of their burden.
And I can say,
you know,
the one thing that I would say to that is the,
the,
the so-called burden.
I think most people who've lost anybody to suicide would say,
I would take that burden any day of the week over losing the person.
So it's,
yeah.
Yeah.
And that's another thing too is I think on my end of it,
I don't realize the impact that I would have if I took my own life.
I'm not aware of how intense that pain would be for other people and the ripple
effect.
I'm starting to learn that,
but I really don't get it.
So there's,
there's two different completely different sides that were just,
yeah,
we need to come together on
amazing.
You can hold space for both of those truths and perspectives at once and trying
to integrate the two.
And we talk about the listener kind of being that opportunity to just to open
the door to hopefully get people help.
But I also just want to acknowledge that it can be very hard once people start
that process.
Um,
and that the,
there's a lot of barriers of access to care,
not only in the US,
but globally.
Um,
and to give credence to that.
I'm hoping we can roll the clip of collection and then we can talk about that a
bit.
Yeah.
Anytime you attempt,
you first have to go to village medical hospital where they like make sure
everything's okay.
I have this nurse told me,
you know,
don't let yourself get raped again.
I'm in a psych ward and I'm like,
Oh,
I want to react to this and you have power over me.
And you think the helpful thing is to tell me not to get raped again.
Meanwhile we're watching like they're actually showing silence of the lambs in
the mental hospital and I'm like I telling the nurses,
the Lincoln,
you guys think this is like our appropriate ookay shows.
Make that,
make that shit up.
What I learned from being in the hospital was how never to be in a hospital
again.
You know,
there are still ups and downs.
I mean,
you know,
I find ways through music,
through my Karaoke,
through my poetry to live better.
It was a big smashing this mask of I'm going to make you laugh and make you look
that way.
Oh my God,
secrets made me sick.
That's what I really think about it.
Oh,
I want more of your hand in that,
but look at that shit.
That's my faith.
Hey,
it's okay.
It's not bad.
I'm just struck by the picture of her again at the end.
Collette,
you,
you can really just see in her eyes.
Right.
Um,
I'm just,
it's being in the system,
me as a mental health professional and having also personal experiences with,
uh,
folks in my family who,
um,
have had issues with suicidal thoughts and such.
It's so hard the system.
And I just want to acknowledge as part of the system itself,
um,
it is broken and I'm just curious to hear from you all,
uh,
what barriers you noticed both interviewing folks in going through it yourself.
Okay.
I just want to say one thing I learned recently,
I was just at this conference in Santa Fe and this woman stood up,
she was a social worker and she said,
we always say the system's broken.
I mean the system is a mess.
But when you say the word broken because we all say that cause it really,
it is pretty easy to say and it,
you know,
it's kind of clear,
but like what other word was speaking of words and terminology,
what other word can we use?
The chose like,
okay,
we're on it,
we're working,
we're making it better.
We're doing something to make it better rather than,
oh well it's broken because it does seem like a throwaway thing.
But having said that,
yeah,
no,
you,
you should talk about your,
um,
your experience but,
but yeah,
like talking to collect tea and talking and layer layer.
Oh my God.
I mean she,
I'm in fact,
we were just talking today about something else and she's like,
I think psychiatrists,
I think there'll be gone in 50 years because,
yeah,
that's not real science.
And you know,
and me,
she's had such bad experiences when she was 15.
She was told you will be,
she was in a,
um,
an uh,
she was at a psychiatric hospital and she,
you will be here for the rest
of your life.
You will never get better.
So,
you know,
this was her experience.
Obviously that doesn't happen with everybody in there.
Some really good psychiatrist and there are others who say things like that.
So it's uh,
yeah.
But your experience,
yeah,
as far as psychiatrists go,
I do have one that I think is fabulous.
There's only a limit to so much that he can do.
You know,
um,
you know,
there's medications,
there's tms,
there's all these different things you can try,
but sometimes they don't always work.
But,
um,
I think my experience with the medical system,
uh,
when you're 51 50 and you're taken away for a suicide attempt or at risk of
attempting,
um,
they will take you by ambulance.
Hopefully if you're lucky,
sometimes an ambulance doesn't come.
So the police,
we'll handcuff you and take you,
which is very demeaning.
That did not happen to me.
But they'll take you to an emergency room generally first,
and you'll be evaluated and then you'll end up in a bed.
And,
um,
my experience with that was very uncomfortable.
Um,
generally the nurses at the time,
and I'm hoping things have changed a lot better,
but my experiences that they disapproved of what I had done and so did not want
to give me the care that they would give other patients.
Um,
at the same time,
there is a security guard sitting in a chair looking at you the whole entire
time because you're at risk to society.
So it makes you feel like you're a criminal after you go to the emergency room,
then you go to a psychiatric Atrik hospital and it's locked down.
You know,
you're,
you're stripped of shoelaces and ties and you know,
hairdryers and jewelry and you're stripped of everything and um,
and then you just,
you just have to accept that and,
and you can't leave.
You're locked.
You're,
you're treated as a criminal.
And I don't know what the solution is.
I don't know how to prevent that from happening,
but it's a horrible experience.
Now,
once I realized that it was locked down and I,
and there were times when I knew I needed to protect myself because I was not
safe.
I would voluntarily checked myself into a psychiatric hospital and I have
probably done that 10 times beyond my suicide attempts because it's the only
safe place I can be.
So that's,
that's what is given to us and unfortunately it's not a very good situation.
Yeah.
It's,
it's so hard.
And as a clinician,
I always really struggled with making that decision because I know it was going
to be a hard process,
but I knew that's where somebody would be safe.
And,
um,
you know,
but it's interesting because now I still struggle with suicidal thoughts.
Sometimes I am at risk.
Um,
but I think jumping to the conclusion,
I've,
the therapists and psychiatrists that I work with,
the last thing they want to do is to put me in the hospital because
that could be more detrimental at times.
Okay.
Um,
so it's really knowing what that limit is.
I can say I have suicidal thoughts.
I can say I have a means of how to do it right next to me.
And,
and I,
you know,
they're not gonna send me to the hospital unless I've already taken something or
done something to hurt myself.
But they know,
they know that limit,
how far to take it because it is a bad experience to be in a hospital in a
psychiatric hospital and the stigma,
I'm glad you have that relationship with your providers so you can work together
to know what that line is.
I'm very lucky.
I even have a psychiatrist and therapist
so,
and Lisa,
I really appreciate you challenging the language around that and I was
reflecting on that,
FDA said that and it's like maybe the system is developing,
maybe,
I don't know.
It's going through growing pains,
something so that it still is kind of this necessary part of the process,
but maybe we can tolerate the tension or those hiccups where it doesn't work so
well knowing it's hopefully going to inevitably,
and I don't know,
maybe this talk is going to inspire somebody to go out and to continue to
improve what's there.
We've come so far in 50 years,
I can only imagine what the next 50 is going to bring us.
[inaudible].
Yeah.
Cause you know,
the one thing that I've heard and you would know about this,
the idea of when people talk about people with a diagnosable mental illness
dying younger,
and do you think you think,
oh well suicide or you know,
whatever.
But apparently there is a whole thing and you may know about this,
if you go in for heart palpitations or whatever it may be and somebody looks at
your chart and sees,
oh,
bipolar disorder,
you're okay.
You know,
go home.
So I mean I've heard that like,
like somebody in our,
in our previous film,
she went in for a Migraine and they saw that she had a history and that she had
bipolar disorder and they sent her home.
I mean,
you know,
when you hear about things like that,
that's sort of the flip side of this.
That is pretty upsetting.
That's,
yeah,
very upsetting.
And I have heard stories like that and it is not best practices,
but I,
but I acknowledge that,
I've heard stories like that too.
Yeah.
And,
um,
if you are struggling,
please know that there's hope and that you can get help and please reach out for
help.
We have some resources here.
Um,
and to end,
we're going to go ahead and run the clip of Brandon please.
Okay.
Suicide Prevention Center crisis
lost your job and your
plan of how you would do what we have to do is help people feel safe and
comfortable to talk about something that scares the hell out of them.
And if somebody can connect with you in that moment where feeling like there's
no reason to live,
that takes them out of the aloneness and the moment that they're not feeling
alone,
they're already safer than they were before they spoke with you.
That
she's fine.
I ended up,
well,
I this had to make sure that you had the support that you needed for that too.
Okay.
Now not everybody can do this.
A lot of people care,
but it's sometimes really difficult to put that care and that passion and
compassion into,
um,
different kind of skillset to talk to people who are thinking about suicide.
Brandon proud of was on of our own.
He was a very,
very good counselor.
I think he saved many lives.
How long has it
been since you've had any kind of psychiatric,
oh,
this was way off saying a life,
I think for a number of years.
Are you
proud of?
Was the only shift supervisor I've ever had who had groupies.
Don't want to see the La Cosa.
Don't feel
he was a rockstar.
And,
and that's when he grew his hair really long.
So look like a rock star.
Don't wanna wake up
asking him,
are you suicidal?
I couldn't ask him that early on.
I couldn't even face that.
It was really that side of me that this is all going to end.
He's going to be okay.
Oh,
anybody who has lost anyone through suicide,
you always say,
what did I miss a what?
Why couldn't I say?
Yep.
What did I do wrong?
And who doesn't have one right now?
I really don't have an answer to that.
And you know,
the last thing we want,
I think this is true with everybody,
is to forget our loved one.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.